un jeune homme est jugé cette semaine
j'ai donné le 18 entre cette faible
réglable robin n'en parlons pas de
parler des étriers pense que lui pose sa
voix parce qu'ils savent rien en général
[Musique]
sur ces images du canada toujours débat
même si belles images mais là où j'en
avais on a mis un peu d'aidé là dedans
vous écoutez pas à pas et vous regardez
dans ce moment également la version de
tomtom cana dans la version en direct
qui a pas de version en différé
malheureusement pas encore alors on fait
bien des parts sociales émission mais on
est toujours entouré d'amis alors autour
de la table cette semaine raymond des
marteaux bonjour qui a accepté encore
une fois avec grande générosité dire va
jouer avec nous à l'émission aujourd'hui
martine aubry de la section anglaise
bonjour - bonjour bonjour il manque pas
quelqu'un à côté de vous mais c'est ça
c'est mary claude qui est normalement là
sauf qu'elle était dans notre bonne
émission c'est plutôt faisant la pêche
sur l'île sainte hélène qui est juste à
l'autre côté de la rivière de montréal
en 2008 un train de l'avenir de partir à
la pêche aux infos qu'elle revienne
et puis nous à paris jacques boutault 3
4 minutes tout sourit en se disant si
j'arrive en retard ce que je le vois
quand même participé l'émission j'ai dit
oui ça fait partie du jeu j'ai toujours
comment ne pas arriver sous les gravats
parlant de saint louis est équipé d'un
grand montréal comment ils sont proches
de la nature
c'est comme ça d'un voyage ouais on a
deux cycles et c'est une pêcheuse voilà
alors prenez le temps de vous déséquipés
comme si seulement on pouvait exister et
c'est une brèche montpellier cannes à
pêche
je suis seul est ce que c'est un mordu
alors les les grands ici autour de la
table ceux qui sont branchés au micro
vous allez jouer avec nous aujourd'hui à
la découverte du sujet de l'annoncé
parti à vous connaissez pas le sujet y'a
que marie-claude qu'il connaît cette
semaine oui on peut dire que oui
grâce à vous il ya une émission
aujourd'hui alors voici on présente la
vidéo numéro 1 5 images dès que vous
sentez que vous êtes sur la piste vous
criez
ramdam oui j'ai de beaux yeux à ce choix
là est ce qu'on parle de communication
animale ou de cruauté animale
on pourrait parler des deux mais je
pense qu'on va surtout parler du 2e qt
et animale ouais
eh ben ce fameux règlement sur les
chiens dangereux csn lorsque l'on parle
de chat le sentez vous l'a dit un jour
il m'a enlevé des griffons au chat qui
s'est en fait c'est une amputation
c'est ça c'est une opinion critique ah
oui en tous cas ma bulle et on va au
revoir à profondeur à faire jeudi c'est
une pratique
certains m'ont fait serait sa coupe et
longue d'un être humain c'est la
meilleure chance d'être la dernière la
chine a largement du jeu vous avez des
épis ont déjà très bien l'arrêter
non parce que les gens de l'est on
reconnaît l'absidiole des camps et puis
moi je vis avec une spécialiste en
comportement animal à c'est un avantage
car total absolu
alors écoutez ça c'est fantastique que
vous soyez donc l'expert encore une fois
c'est un peu notre chouchou moi j'écoute
qu'est-ce qui se passera s'il ya un
problème de caméra y'a jamais de
problèmes de caméra sur ce plat duke et
des solutions pour mériter ça alors je
pense qu'on va être prêt pour la
première premier jeu de la grosse boule
vous connaissez la tradition vous
risquez de perdre tous 20 points il ya
20 il ya 100 points à perdre dans chaque
émission à quand notre invité surprise
se fout carrément de nous avec ce nous
on voit qui est cet invité sur ça et
puis nous ne venons pas encore le loisir
de regarder ces images qu'elle qu'elle
produit avec du rose et du blues et mais
les plus belles couleurs et des
visionnements on va garder le plaisir
pour le dessin pendant quelques instants
qu'elle flags pour le moment la première
ronde on regarde la premier jeu la
question qui est posée
voici en 2018 ce bien non ça la nouvelle
écosse est la colombie-britannique terre
neuve et labrador ainsi que l'île du
prince édouard ont interdit cette
chirurgie pratiquée sur les chats et
d'autres provinces dont l'alberta le
manitoba du nouveau-brunswick
le ferait ou le feront prochainement
huit mois dans combien de pays dans le
monde
on interdit cette pratique du dégriffage
chez les chats est-ce que c'est à 10 b
20 c 40 ou des 80 moi je 40 40 c mais je
vais bien a dit disent pas beaucoup de
pays comme ce qu'elles en font mousser
40 pour vous aussi
d'accord et puis moi je dirais aussi le
mois jurés 40 c 40 on regarde la petite
étoile
ça va vous m'envoyez et l'automatique ça
vous dit que vous avez la bonne réponse
du game 6 nations il ya parmi les pays
qui proscrit maintenant le défrichage de
negri farwell plus tôt je fais des trucs
sexy l'eia la france le royaume uni
l'australie l'allemagne l'autriche la
belgique le brésil le danemark la
finlande la norvège la suède israël la
suisse et la turquie
ça vous fait certainement nous deux on a
vécu en allemagne pendant plusieurs
années
et moi je me suis bien là les dernières
années où j'étais l'autre que dans le
journal local de la tong avait des
encarts et les bd des commentaires
parlant de nous canadiens quel point
était sauvage à qu'elle concède encore
des griffes et nos chats ça c'est je
pense que c'est une pratique culturelle
au canada j'ai ouï dire qu'au canada
anglais c'est moins populaire ah ben oui
je sais pas comment ça se passe en
ontario j'ai pas d'information là-dessus
je pense que la meilleure chose à faire
c'est demander à une spécialiste de la
question du sort des animaux de se
présenter sa démission la voici la voilà
s'agit du docteur caroline qu'ils donc
président de l'ordre des médecins
vétérinaires du québec
bonjour docteur bon écoutez je fais des
grandes affirmations je suis un peu
comme mes collègues je ne sais pas
toujours de quoi je parle
alors les brigades radio est ce que vous
avez dit eh bien eh bien mes
poursuivants est vrai aussi mais voyons
comment ça se passe dans les autres
provinces
j'entends souvent parler du québec qui
est un des bobs le plat là je vois qu'en
un an seulement plusieurs provinces ont
dit non en un an seulement il y en a
d'autres qui s'apprêtent à le faire
qu'est ce qui se passe exactement au
niveau d'il ya un momentum ou quoi vous
savez de manière générale et humains ont
de plus de réticence à pratiquer des
chirurgies au nom médical qui dit
c'est ce juste l'évolution de la société
qui est un peu comme ça alors on a été
sensibilisée à ce que au québec on parle
depuis déjà arrivé une heure et puis on
demandé on vaccine et votre chaton voici
le programme de vaccination et puis on
vous recommande de stériliser alors
voulez-vous faire dégriffer de juste
comme ça vu john ce que vous avez dit
entendre que c'est une amputation
veulent avant tout à fait je lance une
application persil et la dernière
phalange parce que de cette façon qu'on
empêche complètement la guérir de
boucher on est plus conscient maintenant
ce que ça implique
c'est une chirurgie lorsque bien en voie
de conséquente mais comme toute
chirurgie comporte des risques de
complications et de soutien on essaie
maintenant de chirurgie comme celle de
roupies alors nous alors de faire un
dépliant pour les médecins vétérinaires
pour informer leurs clients parce
qu'encore beaucoup de clients qui vont
demander y a encore beaucoup de
jusque remporte deux choses si leur
chope pour être alors on veut participer
un changement de plus rapide de
possibles mais la façon de faire à ce
moment ci selon nous est vraiment la
conscientisation et des ducs est
lyonnais et où le site permet le
professionnel au québec
vous savez combien on est distinct du
reste du canada et pourquoi alors venue
des associations de médecins vie
communale qui peuvent adopter des
positions qui sont les positions de
leurs membres
on note et on a dû opposer car
réglementaire un organisme qui
réglemente la pratique la médecine
vétérinaire et nous cessons on est alors
qu'ils ont des devoirs et
responsabilités donc bien un borloo et à
la médecine vétérinaire on était
vraiment totalement au service de
l'humain donc de plus en plus avec la
concertation de la population
l'évolution des mentalités
on est aussi de plus en plus des
promoteurs dans tous les débats pré
vente au québec et je sais que vous vous
avez donc amorcé et l'explication pour
nous expliquer où vous vous situez dans
le débat il faut expliquer où se situe
maintenant le débat il ya spa à montréal
qu'à lancer une campagne pour obliger
tout le monde à cesser cette opération
vous vous faites une opération
d'éducation c'est ce que vous proposez
alors que dans d'autres provinces au
canada où on a décidé de trancher c'est
l'interdiction
et rappelons que des pays ont décidé non
l'éducation on interdit ça me semble un
petit peu nous semblait un peu à droite
d'un phénomène de gauche présente mois
de disette en politique non considéré
réseau centré je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que la société québécoise est pas
au même endroit que ces autres sociétés
le ou de ces autres sociétés noah était
au moment des deux
des interdictions vu qu'on y est on est
dans un contexte culturel ou la
chirurgie était très très pratique et
alors nous notre but est pas de se
situer dans un extérieur ou un autre de
la polarisation parce que d'un côté on a
des gens qui sont très militaire et qui
dramatise quand même les conséquences il
ya des images choc circulent et ou qui
dramatise beaucoup les conséquences de
la chirurgie par rapport à ce qui
signifie qu mans a démontré l'autre
extrême serait de continuer comme
c'était dans les décennies précédant la
france et que c'est tout à fait anodin
pana les plus petits programmes lourds
puisque on n'a pas de considérer dont on
tient pas compte de considérations
éthiques du fait que c'est quand même
une application partielle une jeune
fille nommée tiana nécessaire que ça
change le comportement de l'animal est
tous au alors on se trouve présentement
beaucoup plus au centre
et puis c'est aussi une volonté de ne
pas être une organisation qui vient qui
vient divisé et trancher dans la
population mais au contraire participer
l'évolution à l'avancement la
progression de la confiance et
conscientisation des populations
vous dites qu'au québec on part de loin
de fait on part de loin dans le cas de
plusieurs animaux chiens et chats natama
chien on a été pendant très longtemps la
capitale des nations
du canada la de plus en plus il ya des
moyens qu'ils entendent ça prendra
encore un peu plus dans 14 est un fait
mais on parle aussi dans le code du
tchad
oui mais mon divan de cuir qu'est ce que
je vais faire alors que c'est tout à
fait possible de conditionner un chat à
ne pas toucher à ce fameux divan cuit
exact il mobilise dans les dizaines
d'entrevues j'ai donné sur le sujet
c'est ce dont j'ai fait la promotion
constamment de ses autres manières de
faire nos qui vont quand même empêché
des dommages aux meubles des gens donc
il remplir les besoins comportementale
de l'animal de tailler les griffes
régulièrement des champs leur trouver un
call for le qui conviait parce que tous
les joueurs ont les mêmes références en
la matière que je vais revenir sur ce
que vous dites à propos des usines à
chiots
c'est un phénomène qui est vraiment si
la quantifier
une chose est certaine on progresse dans
ce domaine là aussi
puis même présentement déjà la loi sur
le bien-être animal l'augmentation est
en plus présente mr bon travail avec le
mapaq et le ministère de sécurité
recommandations pour leur part de
remettre des élevages en général ça
découle du dossier des chiens dangereux
mais ça vaut quand même un effet
bénéfique sur les élevages
alors quoi voyez-vous l'important moi je
sors un peu défaitiste le cas on se
compare aux autres qu'on est les
derniers
de fait les coûts je pense que
l'important c'est de la société ou à
l'épée de la faire progresser
puis arrêter de se dévaloriser plaisir
le corner des derniers mais il ya une
autre question qui rentrent dans cette
discussion avec lesdites dégriffage des
choses s'agit des chiens et le coupage
des oreilles et le coeur pour des fins
esthétiques qui est aussi interdite dans
d'autres provinces
ouais nation c'est interdit
aussi notre ordre or interdit la
pratique de la taille des oreilles et
des que par les médecins vétérinaires
parce que notre seul pouvoir nous à
l'ordre et sur la pratique des médecins
mais tellement d'autres distinguer
autrement dit quelques années notre
s'est engagé sur la voie des
interdictions
il ya beaucoup de questions à se poser à
savoir si c'est notre rôle
je vous ai expliqué en tant qu' il ya
une grande évolution dans la perception
même par les médecins vétérinaires de
leur rôle mais il faut faire attention
pour les birmans à fléchir où on sent à
bord avec sa part une réflexion profonde
avant de continuer dans la voie des
interdictions parce que plus au maire de
l'interdiction plus les gens vont penser
que par défaut tout ce qui n'est pas
interdit est permis
puis ça ça demande beaucoup de réflexion
ensuite nous on n'a aucun pouvoir de la
part des lois de réglementer sur le
bien-être animal
on n'est pas un organisme de
réglementation sur le bien-être animal
nous nous ne pas pouvoir donner par la
loi sur les médecins vétérinaires par
l'office des professions donc le code
des professions
notre pouvoir ses seules même sur
l'exercice des médecins vétérinaires
alors à ce moment ci on se demandait une
profonde réflexion de savoir si on
continue à s'aventurer dans une
direction qui n'est pas dans la veine de
notre pouvoir réglementaire
immédiat c'est une réplique réflexions
philosophiques profonds des avoirs
et puis les médecins vétérinaires sont
toujours ou car la relation humains
animaux
et puis non si on a bien je vous donne
un exemple exagéré par exemple le cyan
venir que
on dit qu'une majorité de médecins petit
renard voudrait que des grippes ajoie
interdit et on l'a interdit est ce que
ça veut dire que dans dix ans si une
majorité des médecins vétérinaires
désapprouve la consommation bien on peut
plus avoir des médecins vétérinaires qui
travaillent dans les indics et animale
malgré le fait que parce que c'est parce
que on serait tous comme des défenseurs
du bien-être animal alors que ça répond
à un besoin de la population mais aussi
réflexions à ce moment-ci
et il ya aussi je dirais un conflit
relation entre le patient qui l'animal
auquel vous avez votre allégeance et le
client qui est le propriétaire de
l'animal dieu merci on allait plus aux
biens meubles mais il ya cet aspect
bicéphale aussi de votre travail en tant
que terminal le sol arable la pédiatrie
où des jeunes enfants qu'ils peuvent
pour donner leur consentement et je le
donne souvent un exemple qui font pas
des chirurgies servir des enfants qui
ont les auraient trait décoller parce
qu'il pense que peut-être que lanvin
plus tard être complexé à cause de ses
oreilles décollées
moi on me dit que c'est douloureux je
pense donner un consentement éclairé la
même chose pour de l'orthodontie c'est
toujours facile les traitements
d'orthodontie des enfants songeur est ce
que c'est vraiment chaud l île de la mer
sont les exemples parker qui laisse donc
vous m'amenez sur la fin de cet échange
moi j'ai eu j'ai encore de charges
réussissent depuis l'âge de 18 ans j'ai
commencé la nasa j'étais dans mon chien
mais là j'ai changé amenderait
complètement ses échappements
alors vous c'est peut-être tous les
animaux je pense je suis
que vous êtes pour l'instant on n'en a
plus depuis le décès de notre gordon
connu pendant 12 ans à qui va piano va
sano moins depuis que moi à chaque fois
que je trouve ça je pense à ma propre
éducation mon opinion là dessus a changé
il ya 4 5 ans moi je vous l'accordé les
faits mais chasse était absolument
nécessaire
aujourd'hui les proches un chat ce sera
non je vais chercher une autre façon de
m'occuper raison et ce au taux moyen non
parce que j'ai compris le sien ouais
c'est moi c'est la douleur qui fait qui
me fait peur et ça je ne sais pas les
animaux espère comme les enfants
jedediah peuvent pas s'exprimer lorsque
nous leur nécessairement qu'est ce que
ressentent les chats lorsqu'ils se font
couper les par les ongs les griffes
c'est sûr que le moment de
l'intervention
[Musique]
les médecins ont tenu un protocole et
qui durent pendant deux jours des cds
connaissances qui sont récents et qui
font partie du débat combien
personnellement je vois la pratique est
en déclin
les jeunes vêtir nano pratique parce que
plus la chirurgie la potion situation de
la population à la pratique est en très
grande et claire et pour des raisons etc
et c'est très bien
on s'y oppose pour des raisons est ce
qu'à un moment donné on va preuves
scientifiques qui vont montrer très
clair pour acceptable par moi j'ai
confiance que de toute façon au cours
des prochaines sur kibo pratiquement
merci beaucoup de records at il pas
devenu complètement inacceptable que ce
soit fait de vous dire sans proposer
des solutions de régie alors c'était le
19e entrevue cette semaine
champion ça a duré à peu près 19 minutes
c'était une occasion assez rare ou de
vraiment expliquer le fond de la faire
tout seul c'était bien agréable d'avoir
cet échange la merci merci beaucoup au
revoir
alors docteur caroline qui donc
président de l'ordre des médecins
vétérinaires du québec à vous revoir
mais pourquoi je voulais je vais avoir
présenté les missions non je comprends
pas on y va pour deuxième tour vagabonde
moi si vous êtes bien entraîné comme un
singe oui mais là ce sont les deux
boutons x marque tient la maison vide et
arrivant je vais vous montrer la
deuxième question c'est pas facile il ya
trente points 30 points à peine 39 à
perdre cette semaine et c'est très
difficile je soupçonne vous allez tous
ceux qui perdent des plumes dans les
milieux médicaux comme on nomme ton
cette opération qui consiste à enlever
les griffes un chat ou des ongles un
être humain s à une lobo ni etc tommy
radical
b une non ni aux économies radicales
c'est une eau ni économies radicales ou
des noms audio taux légal au lieu de
d'essayer de prononcer ces termes nous
faut c'est ces images à apt encore une
fois pas à une le bonniec tommy
syndicats comme et pour moi j'y vais
aussi pour ses pensées une seconde et
demie radical ces dames et voyez où
apparaît la petite étoile ou perdre et
30 aux griffes face à les classer tous
les ans vous avez tout mon gré ya pas de
douleur écoutez je vous avais compagnie
driss sur la racine du mot qui vous
non c'était un ben moi je savais aussi
mais aussi oui c'est sûr mais surtout
c'est que dans la vidéo qui accompagnait
notre entrevue un moment donné est passé
aussi ça c'est l'indispensable pnud
imaginé jusqu'à maintenant de marcher
plus de marché de la gamme à main vous
présenter une
moi j'ai peut-être on a dit l'une on a
le choix un reportage de radio canada
sur la zone ionique toumi radical bravo
où l'image mystère la vidéo mystère
qu'est ce que vous choisissez la vidéo
mister je préviens la régie technique
pour faire son jardin et maintenant je
peux avoir d'animaux qui a fondé soit
enlevé cinq mois la vie austère oui
regarde ça ensemble
pas d'animaux promis par un démon j'ai
ma promesse alors voici c'est une eau ni
au lectorat dicale sur un être humain
pour l'inclusion parce que je vois c'est
parce que cette semaine en faisant oui
mais c'est je prépare cette émission est
d'abord un petit peu quand même et je
regarde ça de manèges et là je dirais je
finis par comprendre qu'est ce que c'est
que cette histoire de dégriffage d'une
chope à quel point je veux plus me
mettre mes petits animaux favoris à quoi
que ce soit est ce grave
et ça je le connais très bien l'ayant
subi sur un pied moi même c'est pourquoi
on fonce à moi dans mon cas c'était
c'est un ongle incarné qui va pousser de
façon interne et donc fallu enlever la
racine et tous ont pour elles je regarde
passer sur un être humain à gaza c'est
la tombola à des proches
c'est ça joue dur c'est dur
acer dell et duda parce que dans le cas
de l'ong incarner fonds sera écouté
j'avais 20 ans et je m'en souviens
encore aujourd'hui dans le cas de
l'ongle incarné de donc il ya une
infection en dessous donc quand on y va
pour une anesthésie ça fait un peu là
dedans j'ai entendu parler de ce nom le
plus douloureux c'est qu'il peut pas
courir après les filles c'est un seul
problème vous alliez pas loin c'est quoi
ça chaque fois que des plages cherchait
qu'à fait preuve noir steijns a pas
écoutés on sort on va merci
image vidéo pour votre mission non non
je pense que c'est à ses yeux
peut-être que c'est une comparaison il
ya joué fort bien joué par certains mais
je trouve que moi ça m'a touché cette
semaine ça ça m'a convaincu de ne plus
jamais même parlé de ça avec un
vétérinaire
je puis est ce que j'ai remarqué parce
que moi aussi j'avais déjà dans ma
jeunesse est un des shows a été des
glyphes et et j'ai remarqué un
comportement un changement de
comportement parce que l'animal s'est il
sait que il peut plus défendre comme ça
donc il mord plus souvent troisième tour
de la grosse boule il ya cinquante
greffe à perdre
et puis bella se faisaient tous les cas
tous conservés je suis sur la feue la
réponse est tellement facile ont fait
apparaître à l'écran la question mais
c'est bon c'est l'attitude à ces bleus
ok alors y'a hôtelier 11
il y avait 16 millions d'animaux
domestiques au pays
chiens chats et puis crocodile pour 35
millions citoyens canadiens
maintenant on est un peu plus de se
montrer 36 millions et plus combien
étaient des chats sur ces 5 millions
d'animaux domestiques à 5,5 millions bep
8,1 millions ou c'est 10,2 millions -
jort pour b parce que dans les nouvelles
il ya souvent des personnes qui ont un
vin chaud à la maison
est ce d'avoir un chien on va même
raison avait poussé c'est alors voila c
et c'est bien dommage j'avais tous perdu
50 griffe parce que la bonne réponse et
attendez voir marrant non c'est elle qui
a usé ses désirs c'est ça j'ai dit j'ai
dix essais semafo c'est moi qui n'allait
pas et perd donc vous avez perdu 50
points tenant lui égalé je suivais sous
copié sur l'eau serait pas de problème
alors ça va bien c'est plus de chats le
point que voulez vous que je vous dise
amené ici soumettre ces cas plus de
chartes le chien dans les foyers les
canadiens louis borloo moi je vous dis
ce que j'imagine que ça fait la
compilation des des hamsters des souris
des paysans caire probablement parce
qu'il y ait plus en plus de gens qui
vivent en milieu urbain dans des
appartements et des condos donc le choc
peut s'il a seulement déchets sont pas
permis alors les prêts maintenant mais
c'est ça aussi bien les observer à avoir
un animal un chien quand vous voulez
vraiment vous occuper de votre chien
correctement ces quelques milliers de
dollars par année ça sera ça prend 10
minutes au cinéma avec la fia avec le
chat avec le chien non ça ce nouvel
animal non ça s'en vient les photos de
claudia
en anglais on l'appelle de dates seront
actés lors les prêts là c'est sûr c'est
l'image la semaine et puis moi je vous
parie 100 millions que vous ne devinerez
pas deux mois la semaine je sais c est
ce que ça parle d'une d'avortement non
jamais
est-ce que ça se fasse au canada n'ont
pas tout à fait c'est en europe ça se
passe partout d'allemand mais dans le
monde partout dans le monde
en théorie totalement mais en provenance
de certains pays en particulier relation
animal ça à faire avec les relations
animal
bah oui absolument actuellement la bonne
chance à tous c'est concerne un peu les
animaux ça concerne beaucoup les animaux
qu'on a vus comme animaux dans l'est
c'est pour le côté des disparitions
d'espèces sa réplique ça mais c'est pas
masqué d'un document derniers mois
qu'ils sont une étude la musique
s'intensifie oui on a besoin on va tg
cette annonce c'est le sonar du
sous-marin non à l'animal pas de
cachalot ssd animaux marins non pas du
tout
azéma nous qui vole pas du tout bas des
rayons la terrestre
oui d'animaux terrestres y en a deux
volets des mammifères c'est un joli nom
ça vole pas autant que ça inquiète et b
savoie la nuit mieux que nous un
kangourou qui volent parfois oui alors
on va vous le montrer il est décédé
cette semaine on sait grand pic à
tropiques à petit c'est là là là que
c'est des réseaux sociaux ne parle que
de ça entre copolymères way le latin
vous changer d'avis
vous êtes malade une vraie phase de
prise d'eau il est mort à 7 et les
jeunes quand même dur urinaires mais
surtout d'être très jeune pour un chat
sur sept ans la coqueluche des réseaux
sociaux à travers le mans surtout aux
états unis peut être connus que sont
tony key alors groupe i le chat en
france et on dirait raymond le chat ne
peut pas non c'est autre chose
aulas fava a lorsqu'il est d'avenir il
est devenu fameux parce qu'ils étaient
dans des annonces est le fils d'un
chapeau contente de renom pour ça dans
les annonces télévisées
voilà je passe sur au québec on a
beaucoup entendu parler sous le choc
donc les médiations sens bouex faut
vraiment pour savoir ce qui se passe
sinon bon qui a dit achat que les
stations vous avez la bonne réponse w
c'était pas ma semaine ben le pointage
est pas brillé c'est pas encore terminé
ma rue
je dois dire que je suis allergique aux
chats alors j'ai toujours quand même
bloqué l'info concernant les poissons
c'est ça alors c'est pas tout à fait
finie parce que vous allez nous
présenter comme un regard des émissions
de radio canada est assurée grâce à de
nouvelles applications et ont besoin de
vidéo je crois que tous ceux qui nous
écoutent en ce moment c'est certain
qu'ils ont déjà téléchargé l'application
ce qu'on en parle tellement mais ceux
qui ne l'auraient pas fait écouter allez
sur google ou apple stores et trouver
notre application dans l'outil de
recherche vous mettez radio nationale
vous pouvez nous trouver dans 5 langues
différentes français anglais espagnol
arabe chinois et vous choisissez donc la
langue de votre choix ou tout si vous
voulez il faut télécharger ça sur votre
téléphone
et c'était vraiment visuellement c'est
très facile je n'ai manqué que vous
voyez là pas de vente de chevaux non
l'expression anglaise c'est quoi la
vente déjà c'est un biscuit petits
biscuits sucrés
la pala sa langue comment il ya une
belle expression stage donner sa langue
au chat
oui ça c'est c'est quand on veut
question quand on sait pas la réponse
c'est ça la gauche est aussi un outil de
cuisine on pourrait lancer un défi à
ceux qui nous regardent maintenant sur
le web
quels sont les autres expressions sur
les chats moins que vous aimez pas tous
deux ne sont pas littéraire celle que
vous préférez qui concerne les chats
comme un chat botté n'attend pas c'est
dieu ca c c'est bien connu c'est pas
celle là non non plus avoir d art il
faut changer les chevy rim shopping je
viens de ce pc alors à quoi il ya un
chat noir la nuit aussi c'est quoi
on ne voit pas le chat noir non ils
visitent tous les chats sont gris et
voilà mais aussi chantier au vraiment là
s'est lancé il va chanter fort et la
semaine prochaine marie-claude votre
travail et de lire les propositions des
internautes vers le début ou au milieu
ouvert la fin d'émission me fait appel
je vous donne les instructions parce que
je serai pas la semaine prochaine mais
je prends votre plage a quitté pour pour
des vacances ça va chercher à chasser ça
peut-être un chien dans des chaussures
je vais retourner dans les chiens quand
je vais en attendant occupée
je sais pas à la semaine prochaine je
vous salue tous de m'avoir haye
[Musique]